hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
you have a chocolate bar consisting of a
4x6 grid of small squares
what is the minimum number of cuts to
split the bar into its 24 small squares
now there are some restrictions on the
kinds of cuts you can make
each cut has to be along the horizontal
and vertical lines in between the
squares and each cut also has to start
and end at points along the boundary of
a piece of chocolate
the cut cannot intersect itself and
every time you make a cut the chocolate
bar is split into separate pieces you
can only cut one piece at a time
here's an example of the kind of cut you
can make
this problem was asked to first-year
students at a greek university
the mathematician peter winkler
described it as follows in his excellent
book mathematical puzzles a connoisseurs
collection
this ridiculously easy puzzle has been
known to stump some very high powered
mathematicians for as much as a full day
i encourage you to ask this problem to
see if you can stump anyone
but of course you won't be stumping the
many very high powered mathematicians
who watch mind your decisions
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
the answer is you need to cut the bar 23
times
one way to see this is using logic
at the beginning there is one piece and
you have not broken the bar at all
zero cuts
after any one cut the bar will be split
into two pieces
every subsequent cut increases the
number of pieces by one as each time you
split the bar you are dividing some
single piece into two pieces
you can keep cutting the bar until there
are 24 squares
as the number of cuts is always one less
than the number of pieces the minimal
number of cuts is 23
and it actually doesn't even matter
which procedure you use to cut the bar
it will always be 23 cuts to end up with
24 squares
now this is a perfectly valid logical
proof
but some people will prefer a little bit
more formal of an
explanation the answer is that you will
need n minus 1 cuts for a bar with n
squares
and you can prove this using strong
induction
so for the base case
in a bar with one square you need to
make zero cuts and for a bar with two
squares you need to cut the bar one time
now we will assume for all whole numbers
k
where k is greater than or equal to one
but less than n that it takes k minus 1
cuts at minimum to divide the bar into
squares for a bar consisting of k
squares
now assume we have a bar with n squares
after one cut the bar will be divided
into two pieces
one with r squares and another with n
minus r squares
since r and n minus r are less than n
by the induction hypothesis we can split
the first piece into squares using r
minus one cuts and we can split the
second piece into squares using n minus
r minus one cuts
including the first cut we have made a
total of one plus r minus one plus n
minus r minus 1
and this equals n minus 1 cuts and this
completes the proof by induction
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video
these map videos which can be watched
for free on youtube inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they already have over a hundred
million views let's share the beauty of
mathematics with your help we can map
the world a better place please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos watch and share all of mind your
decisions videos
and email me a puzzle or math topic
presh mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon for exclusive rewards
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support